[Music]
in this video we shall dive into the
underground
the part of the world that we rarely
think about of course there are many
videos on gigantic sea monsters
flying monsters and space guide you
while the subterranean ecosystem of this
world and other planets
have produced some of the biggest
monsters ever so in this list we will
exclude the smaller ones
and only include only the extremely
large underground creatures and kaiju
we will take them from games movies and
also tv shows
so here's what we have on this topic at
number 10 we have baragon
his name means rose dragon but he is far
from a dragon
as the conventional sense goes he is
subterranean and a four-legged
mammal-like reptilian creature
with a reddish brown skin a horn on his
forehead
and large floppy dog-like ears the
petals
on his back are inspired by roses in the
showa series baragon borrowed
underground
and survived the cretaceous extinction
event while most of the dinosaurs died
he appeared briefly in destroy all
monsters movie but in gmk he was the
guardian monster of japan along with
mothra and ghidorah and in his
incarnation he was 30 meters tall
or close to 100 feet and weighed 10 000
tons
baragon is a capable tunneler able to
disappear under the earth in a matter of
seconds
number nine hakuja next on this list we
have a kaiju from the pacific rim
universe
appearing in the second uprising movie
it was one of the three kaiju that made
landfall in japan
and later on combined to form the mega
kaiju it is a hexapetal monster covered
in crustation
like armor with a body style similar to
that of an alligator
similar to a mole it is capable of
borrowing many feet or meters
underground
using its armored head to break through
the ground and to ambush and attack its
opponents hakuga's muscles are
strengthened by its molten blood
and its armor-plated spiked tail can
pierce the arm of a heavily armored
mecha
specifically a jaeger in this franchise
it is 53.5 meters long
as per officially stated figures but
honestly it would be around 150 meters
long or 492 feet long
as per our estimates number 8 megalon
this kaiju made its first appearance in
the 1973 godzilla film
godzilla vs megalon megalon
superficially resembles a cross between
a cockroach
and a rhinoceros beetle though standing
upright
despite being an underground creature
megalon is noticeably colorful
combining silver and grey tusks and
claws with an orange and black carapace
and wings megalon's four limbs terminate
with two sharp
drill-like appendages which it uses to
burrow and move beneath the ground
it is a gigantic insectoid being that
lives deep on the ground in the
subterranean kingdom of cetopia
megalodon is seen as the cetopians gone
and it's called upon by them to defend
their home
from various threats it is 55 meters
long or 180 feet long
and 40 000 tons number 7
sarlacc this next one is from the star
wars universe
and they are seen first in the return of
the jedi
the sarlaccs were dangerous carnivorous
creatures as well as one of jabba the
heart's favorite pets
they inhabited a great bit of carcoon in
the dune sea of the planet called
tatooine
it shared common ancestry with other
monstrous star wars alien species
including the rathar the blixes and the
vixes
at 100 meters long its entire body was
buried in sand safe for its massive
mouth
and big tongue the sarlacc has several
appendages that branch off from its
buried body and also have many stomachs
these creatures start a small
almost microscopic spores but they reach
maturity around 30 000 years later
and they could grow up to 100 meters or
330 feet long
number six the great dragon this famous
creature of the star wars franchise
made its first life debut in the second
season of the show the mandalorian
although it was seen first in an older
star wars film
as a skeleton in the tatooine desert in
star wars episode 4
a new hope the greater great dragon was
the larger of two sub-species of great
dragons
they are giant carnivorous reptiles
found on tatooine
they were characterized by their long
neck whip like tail
horns sharp teeth and five pairs of legs
the greater great dragons submerged
themselves in the shifting sand dunes
and would emerge to consume their prey
it was also capable of spitting a highly
corrosive acid onto attackers
the size of these greater great dragons
were estimated to be around 100 meters
or 330 feet long number 5 the muto prime
this is the penultimate stage of a
female muter from legendary godzilla's
monster verse
it looks like the first female muto but
has a hardened
outer shell with razor sharp back spires
upon it
it has also tremor inducing orange
glowing foliams
which are its way of digging underground
and travelling below the surface
it also has several smaller pairs of
full limbs on her chest
and unlike the other two females seen in
2014 and 2019
prime walks on four legs instead of six
as it appears that some limbs were fused
together during the process of
metamorphosis
mutual prime was much larger than dagon
and godzilla 2014
estimated to be around 106 meters or 350
feet tall
and weighing 135 000 tons she could very
well be a very ancient form of the queen
muto
number four the gen and the darwin [ __ ]
on the fourth spot we have club two
monsters together from the monster
hunter franchise
these are two elder dragons that have
specialized their life to live
underground and beneath the desert
landscapes
they are the gen [ __ ] and a darin [ __ ]
the genmoran is an extremely large
monster with a long
almost serpentine-like body shape on
each side of its head a sturdy sharp
ended dust while there's just one sharp
razor sharp horn
on the daryn [ __ ] which also possess a
similar body appearance
unlike its relative the gen [ __ ] its
body is jagged with spine like
protrusions on its forelegs and its back
while the gen [ __ ] is introduced in the
third part
darwin [ __ ] is seen in monster hunter
faux and both of them are around 110
meters or 360 feet long
number three the weirworms seen in the
third hobbit movie
the battle of the five armies these were
worms
are also known as the earth eaters by
the orcs of dulkin's works
and they are extremely gigantic monsters
of middle middle-earth
they were creatures told in the stories
of the hobbits although possibly
mythical
they were thought to be terrible
monsters that made their home in the
last desert
said to be located far to the east of
the shire in the film
they are involved with digging massive
underground tunnels
by which the armies pass through
undetected to launch a surprise attack
in the film they are depicted as
absolutely gigantic
with weta digital stating that these
monsters are 120 meters
or 400 feet long and 75 feet in diameter
number two the sand worms introduced in
the 1965 novel
sand worms are colossal worm-like
creatures that live in the desert planet
called arakis
these sunworms were also seen in 1984
movie
the 2000 mini series dune and the 2003
children of dune
and will also make a comeback this year
with the remake of the original movie
these sand worms were gigantic life
forms of the planet arrakis
and lives in the vast deserts and sand
dunes that stretch across the surface of
the planet
sun worms live beneath the sand these
huge creatures are thought to grow up to
one thousand meters or
3300 feet long but that is just legend
behind these bees in the dune universe
although very rarely some specimens up
to 450 meters long
are spotted by observers in the planet's
deep deserts
and number one the riftworm the biggest
of the underground monsters are these
absolutely enormous
creatures from the game gears of war the
rift worms were massive worm-like
creatures that are
8 to 10 miles or 13 to 16 kilometers
long and half a mile across or 800
meters
they are semi-intelligent creatures and
these rift worms created the hollow by
borrowing through the crust
of the planet sarah and they leave
behind their ways
that enriches the soil and acts as a
source of life inside the hollows
the riftworm were viewed as gods by some
of the inhabitants of the planet such as
the
locus and was used by the high priest
antagonist
scorch as a living weapon of mass
destruction
and so with that we come to the end of
the video about the biggest underground
monsters
there are quite a lot of small examples
but that would be in another video i
hope
so hit that like subscribe and bell
button for regular notifications
about our future videos